so i took two shots of the fisa vaccine
i had zero symptoms wow
so and i was wondering well see but
that's my feelings right this is not
because i i felt fine i was waiting did
you have pain at the injection site
uh
no it was kind of pleasant
yeah you felt nothing the next day no
nothing okay no no no tiredness no
exhaustion no
um but see like i have an insane
sleeping schedule i already put myself
through crazy stuff that said
maybe i was expecting something really
bad like i was way
and therefore didn't feel it then but i
also got um
allergy shots
and
those i was out all next day like
exhausted for some reason so that that
gave me like
a sense like okay
at least sometimes i can feel shitty
that's good to know sure and then then
with the vaccine it didn't but the the
question is like how much does my mind
come into play there are the
expectations of symptoms uh
the expectations of
not feeling well how does that affect
the sort of the self-reporting the
symptoms i think it's definitely
a variable there but um there's
certainly many people that don't feel
anything after the vaccines and there's
some that have a whole range of
things like soreness and fever etcetera
you